zeitschriften lesen
ein zeitvertreib den die deutschen
lieben die berlinerin birgit von krug
macht es sich am liebsten auf der couch
mit den bunten blättern gemütlich dafür
lässt sie sogar das smartphone links
liegen für mich ist es irgendwie so ein
abtauchen so am wenn ich mir übers
internet was angucke dadurch dass ich
auf den ganzen tag am rechner sitzen bei
der arbeit ist es für mich eigentlich
auch mehr so wie die arbeit also selbst
wenn ich damit auf dem sofa sitze oder
so dann ist es für mich nicht wirklich
entspannt mit es auf dem laptop oder auf
dem ipad oder so anzugucken
bild von krug liest am liebsten
frauenzeitschriften die sie mit
positiven themen unterhalten
das liegt im trend stiegen mode leben
mit der natur kochen schöne themen die
zum träumen und zur flucht aus dem
alltag verführen
immer neue magazine kommt auf den markt
sowie emotionslos eine zeitschrift rund
um das thema entschleunigung
bei uns heißen kapitel zum beispiel
essen mit mehr genuss einkaufen mit mehr
wissen arbeiten mit mehr ruhe haben
reisen mit mehr echo oder auch wohnen
mit mehr gefühl man hört jetzt immer ein
mehr mehr mehr mehr interessante ist
aber eigentlich dass unser besonderes
konzept das weniger propagiert unser
mehrwert liegt darin dass wir sagen man
braucht gar nicht so viel sondern das
richtige
nur vier mitarbeiterinnen sitzen in der
kleinen hamburger redaktion gerade
arbeiten sie an der zweiten ausgabe die
mitte oktober erscheint
genauso wichtig wie interessante artikel
ist für die macherinnen die gestaltung
des heftes zum beispiel mit hochwertigem
papier und ästhetischen fotos man nimmt
es wieder zur hand und man hat etwas was
man tatsächlich auch nachhaltig bewahren
und aufheben möchte und das glaube ich
ist in der allgemeinen entwicklung des
marktes etwas was auch zukunftsfähig ist
magazine ein stück weit auch wie bücher
zu behandeln wir etwas was wert hat was
qualität hat auch das ist typisch für
den deutschen zeitschriftenmarkt eine
riesige auswahl an magazinen
zugeschnitten auf die unterschiedlichen
interessen birgit von krug ist
stammkundin in diesem berliner
zeitschriftenladen hier lässt sie sich
gerne inspirieren und wählt nach
unterschiedlichen kriterien aus
es gibt einige auf die warte ich dann
tatsächlich immer schon irgendwie so ein
bisschen grund ja wenn ich zwischendurch
dann noch irgendwie eine brauche dann ja
so nach dem cover eigentlich ja weiß ich
liebe dich selbst finde ich jetzt auch
so ein bisschen ansprechen das ist ja
doch immer irgendwie so ein thema wie
geht man mit sich selber um 267
millionen euro geben die deutschen pro
monat für zeitschriften aus mit jeder
dritte titel der über die ladentheke
geht es seit weniger als zehn jahren auf
dem markt
stefan scherze vertritt die verleger von
zeitschriften und weiß warum viele der
neugründungen erfolgreich sind
gerade jungen leute sind ja gewohnt
durch im internet finde ich zu jedem
thema ein blog eine website also die
vertikalisierung ist er enorm ausgeprägt
und das bietet auch die deutsche
zeitschriftenlandschaft das heißt was
die menschen durch die digitalen medien
lernen finden sie auch am kiosk
abgebildet sie finden zu jedem noch so
vertikalen thema finden sie einen titel
der mit leidenschaft mit begeisterung
mit tollen bildern gemacht ist die
heutige vielfalt hat auch historische
gründe
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg sollte in
deutschland eine breit gefächerte
medienlandschaft entstehen alle verlage
konnten ihre blätter schon damals über
ein bundesweites vertriebsnetz überall
anbieten international eine besonderheit
wir haben eine sehr starke lesekultur
wir haben in deutschland auch im
vergleich zu vielen ländern im
angloamerikanischen raum vor allem auch
eine gute bezahlkultur das heißt die
menschen erkennen den wert von
gedrucktem im abonnement aber auch am
kiosk
wir haben in deutschland was ganz
wichtig ist eine gute distribution das
heißt sie finden wirklich im hintersten
eck noch eine 1 zeitschriftenladen ein
kiosk einen kabakow anlagen wo sie
zeitschriften bekommen gut verkaufen
lässt sich aber nur was auch mit inhalt
und kompetenz punkten
darauf setzt der hamburger verlag der e
motion slow herausgibt
geschäftsführerinnen angeliefert schätzt
die flexibilität eines kleinen verlags
wenn ihr von einer idee überzeugt sind
und sagen wir trauen uns das risiko
zumindest ansatzweise überschaubar dann
machen wir das einfach anstatt da jetzt
noch ein halbes jahr strategiesitzung
und budgetplanung etc zu verbringen
sondern probieren das dann einfach aus
und sind damit natürlich oft auch
schneller mit verschiedenen dingen am
markt auch birgit von coop probiert beim
lesen gerne neues aus aber dem medium
zeitschrift bleibt sie treu
ich mag das so dass anzufassen und dann
die seiten umzublättern und wenn ich was
interessantes sehe das vielleicht auch
rauszureißen oder so oder
klar kann man sich auch alles im
internet angucken aber das ist nicht so
meins aber wenn birgit von krug auf dem
papier eine anregung entdeckt
fotografiert und speichert sie sie
inzwischen auch auf dem smartphone
die zeitschrift hat den sprung in die
digitale zeit also gleich doppelt
geschafft